welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just to the listeners and viewers but my
next guest who I do believe Chris
Brockman correct me when he first got
the gig in Seattle we called up and had
him part of our Rich Eisen podcast
opener of the season TV show back in the
back of the day that this show was born
out of we were big fans of his the
minute he showed up and said hello to
the Seattle Seahawks fandom when he was
drafted all those many moons ago now in
his eighth season in the NFL getting set
for his fifteenth career playoff start a
Super Bowl champion in his own right
Seattle Seahawks quarterback Russell
Wilson how you been Russell man I'm
doing great how you guys doing from you
again right back at you what would that
kid that came off a campus in Wisconsin
say if he knew the Russell Wilson I'm
talking to right now what would he say
oh man you know it's been a good journey
that's for sure
you know I just keep working you know at
the end of the day you know success and
all that that happens just the
consistency you know through to passion
through through trying to just be
efficient with everything to do and
ultimately you know just try to be
consistent every day you know so you
know I know I know that guy would be
proud of him for sure you know what and
and and that guy came and took the horns
of an opportunity and now here you are
again in the eighth season in the NFL
what now that this is many rodeos in and
you're going to Lambeau Field big-time
playoff game you're used to these what
goes through your mind literally days
before a playoff game like this well it
just just have a winning formula you
know I think winning approached the end
of the day it's about that's how you
prepare it's about you know making sure
that everybody else you're leading
everybody else to prepare the highest
level and you know this is what it comes
down to it comes down to these matchups
and these opportunities and when you get
them you got to take it off you got to
take advantage of them so we're looking
forward to the opportunity I'll just go
on the road we've been road warriors all
year you know it's been an amazing
journey so far for us and we don't we
don't we don't want to stop now and when
you are keeping your head up downfield
again is it just pure instinct or you do
actually
have like an inner monologue that's
going on I know it's a fast game but it
does it does it does seem like you've
got instincts and you've got smarts and
you've got experience all working at the
same time
from my perspective yeah you know I
think somebody's talking to me I don't
know what it is but I think more than
anything else is you just trust your
players you trust your skill position
guys you know they make a lot of great
plays and you try to keep the play alive
as long as you can and they do wonders
man they they just get open they find
ways and you know I'm never looking to
run it you know I'm always looking to
throw it and get the ball to those guys
and let them do work and facilitate the
ball Tilghman so they've been doing a
tremendous job of that all year I mean
even last game we just had so many plays
like that last game that was you know a
really special Tyler on the sidelines I
mean I mean him to get his two feet in
like that was crazy so a lot of those
plays and it's because of those guys
Russell Wilson here on the Rich Eisen
show when did you first realize that DK
Metcalf could be special when did that
happen
honestly our first FaceTime call you
know just he got drafted it wasn't just
a normal one it is honestly we started
talking about where he wanted to go he
started telling me without me even
happen you know he said tell me where he
was gonna go what he's going to do and
he had a vision he had a plan and
anytime somebody has a vision and a plan
you know there was executed and willing
to do what it takes to to sacrifice to
make it happen you know then I believe
anybody can make anything happen and so
he's got all the power in the world but
more importantly he's got he's got the
smarts to do it he's got he's got the
work ethic behind it and you know he's
got the character to do it too so you
know I'm doing everything I can to you
know you know help him be a star and he
definitely is that already so so it was
draft night when you had that
conversation with him he gets drafted
you you get his number and you face as
soon as he got drafted within it's been
10 minutes we're hopped on the phone you
know and then this offseason you know
we trained a bunch in California
together and early mornings you know we
were throwing up but you know throwing
throwing up at UCLA you know at 5:30 in
the morning
you know just putting in work early in
the morning you know down in California
in Southern Cal and San Diego too and
just putting an extra work in a lot of
the other guys too as well and he was
just determined you know he's been like
that every day and you know I give these
scouting reports they're another 12 to
15 pages every week and he
knows every detail of it I mean he knows
every little details that you could
imagine alway from the protections to
their players to the coaches and where
they coach before and then certain plays
of the past that you may want to check
out and look at this and look at that
and just is his study habits are
tremendous and you can't coach that you
either have it and you want to or or you
don't and he's got it well I got to tell
you Russell I mean it looks it I mean
you could see the difference I mean from
knowing only a certain couple routes on
one side of the field at the very
beginning of the season to now it's a
totally different player it seems like
well I don't think the players change I
think that we've evolved with him you
know I think more anything else he's
always had been equipped you know I in
terms of being to run all different
types of routes you know I think you
know in college and they had to run a
lot of go balls and in some slants
everyone's around I was that was mostly
it really you know what I think we've
been able to to you know add to his
repertoire and let him do his thing
Russell Wilson here on the Rich Eisen
show if I told you week one I walk up to
week one Russell Wilson and say guess
what week 17 you're gonna hand the ball
to Marshawn Lynch's gonna score you
would have said what I didn't I didn't I
didn't think this was gonna happen you
know um you know obviously it's tough
because we lost you know great players
in shirt and obviously Chris Carson
penny and then we even lost CJ Prosise
as well and but you know Marshawn Lynch
back you know Hall of Fame type player
and a guy who's I mean so much to this
organization in this city and and he
didn't even to my career you know we've
had a lot of fun together made a lot of
cool plays together in the past and and
so you know he's been great you know
honestly the thing about Marshawn he's
been amazing with just his leadership
and locker room with those guys you know
especially Homer they are you know our
young running back rookie running back
he's he just you know he inspires him to
be great and you know just that
relationships cool to to see and then he
just he just knows how to play the game
you know he saw him in Philly you know
he just you see him fight for that
touchdown and he just knows how to do it
you know and he scored a lot of
touchdowns made a lot of cool plays and
you know he's a spectacular football
player so to be back in the backfield
and how
reunion is this great thing and as me
and him been talking about gotten
finished business so hopefully we can
make it happen yeah Wednesday was the
nine year anniversary of the Beast quake
that preceded your tenure there in
Seattle and just the way that the fans
the twelves react when he scores when he
does anything significant is really
something else and I'm just wondering
what it meant to them to the locker room
even players that weren't around and
that does technically include you when
he was there for the first time for
Beast quake but obviously you were there
for some championship runs well what did
that mean for him to just stroll in and
say I'm here when you need me well you
know I think you know first of all going
back to the Beast quake you know I was I
was I was on the East Coast back then
nine years ago that's like I could I
could feel it I could just watching the
game remember that run I was crazy I
wouldn't even hear the LZ Hawks yet
right but uh you know I think for him to
come back and to be on our football team
just means a lot you know he's you know
he loves winning you know I think he he
knows our winning culture and who we are
and the guys that we have in the locker
room it's it's so you know for him to
come back in and guys have been fired up
to to have them back you know I think
it's been cool and should be honestly a
lot of a lot of the young guys I mean I
would probably say 95% our team were
never on on the same team with him
before you know right as he have so many
young guys were such a young team which
is a good thing for us as we grow and
years to come and so you know just to
have him walk back in the locker room
and play football for us and put the two
four back on it means a lot to our team
but also our fans and everybody else
couple more minutes left with Russell
Wilson Seahawks quarterback before
playing in front of the entire nation on
Fox to wrap up divisional playoff
weekend in Green Bay what a huge game
that's gonna be right here on the Rich
Eisen show what would a Super Bowl mean
for you I know you're a team guy there
is an I in Wilson but you're a team guy
what would winning another one mean for
you Russell well I think there's only
been so many people that have gone to
you know two Super Bowls even one and
you know if to win one and fortunate I
won the second one but to go to two
Super Bowls and when one of them and
then to even go to a third one you know
but the plan is not to just you know
it's it's not just to go there's to win
it you know and to be a you know
they'll have the opportunity to win two
Super Bowls and and you know I got a lot
more career left a lot more things ahead
two and so you know be a perfect time I
know that sure we can't get there until
we get yeah we can't we can't get there
until this week and you know and get
through this practice today
and try to have a great breakfast today
and then and then add it up you know
tomorrow and then go into Sunday and
play great so that's really the only
focus right now no I know and obviously
it's you against the Darius Smith and
the rest of that Packers defense that a
lot of people have overlooked but you
know what we're gonna do in the media
we're gonna say it's Russell Wilson
versus Aaron Rodgers do you view the
matchup how do you view the matchup with
Aaron Rodgers two guys you were easily
the most experienced quarterbacks
successful Super Bowl winning
quarterbacks left in this field of H
Russell you know when you think about
Aaron and all the things he's been able
to do you know and an amazing career
he's had I love watching him play
football you know you know and so he
makes all the kinds of throws you can
imagine and he can do some special
things out there at least his football
team in such a way he's a winner he's
always been one and that's why we play
this game is to win so you know it'll be
a great matchup between two great teams
he's a great quarterback a Hall of Fame
quarterback and and you know I'm looking
forward to the opportunity to just you
know getting on the opportunity to put
on the helmet and go after it again you
know that's every week that's what I
look forward to is suiting up with my
teammates and trying to find a way to
win so that's that's the only thing that
you know I'm sewing on I'm laser focus
on that and yeah that's all I really
matters to be honest with you well the
neat thing is you take the field if the
Vikings win the day before you'll know
if you have an opportunity to play one
more time in Seattle you would have the
NFC Championship game against the
Vikings in your house that is a real
possibility as you and I are sitting
here right now Russell how amazing would
that be for you and your team huh
well I mean that would be huge obviously
to come back home and play in front of
our fans and everything else but we
gotta go you go into a tough environment
this week and do that first you know so
we got to find a way to do that and you
know and this is a really really good
football team we're playing and so we
got to play we had to play a plus
football and you know and then we'll see
at the end of it all you know what it
looks like
last one for you Russell before I let
you
tell me about your charitable works
anything else that you got going on that
we and everybody else could chip in and
be part of what you do up there in
Seattle that's not nationally oh man
yeah well there's so many exciting
things we got going on obviously I why
don't you foundation we've done a lot of
stuff with with you know young kids in
cancer and just raise millions of
dollars for that and so you know it's
been a blessing just to be able to do
that was here and just you know to have
our foundation why not use foundation so
if you all want to find out more about
it and donate and help out kids around
the world you know why not you fdn org
you know and check it out but we have
our you got to come to our golf
tournament we'll celebrity Invitational
a bunch of mop-up insane Cadia if you
want to come I would love to have you
unless you play golf or not but if you
don't we still dance and have a good
time well Russell I can bring a game you
know from about ten yards and in I'm not
too shabby
no but I would love to do it when is the
I'll Drive it and you put it in when are
you talking about when is that when is
that tournament
it's like June so it's like June so you
got it come on fun it's fun to have you
so Russell I don't but yeah we're doing
a lot of amazing things and doing some
cool things so it's a blessing why not
you FD n org is that it what it is
that's one that's how people can okay
yeah hey Russell thanks for the call I
always appreciate our time always love
running into you and I hope to see you
soon and I will look forward to seeing
you on my television set on Sunday
thanks for the call Russ well looking
forward to about talk to you soon right
back at you that's Russell Wilson
Seahawks quarterback right here on the
Rich Eisen show